my scooter journey is now taking me past
gorgeous castles and palaces but it's
also taking me through serious rain and
mud nothing to do but push and that's
killing my legs
this time I only has a short distance to
cover from manheim to Heidelberg where
I'm supposed to find place to relax
supposedly they have a world hotel there
and heidelberg is in southwestern
germany in the state of
baden-württemberg 1782 kilometers from
my starting point unzipped in exactly 18
days i have to be at my destination
haledon vaanga Eck in the far south it
feels endless right now after scooting
around for a few days I feel like a cozy
evening in a nice hotel although Germany
is a very beautiful country I do crave
for some faraway places right now so the
solution is the hip world hotel here in
Heidelberg so let's see how worldly this
hotel really is I can hardly believe it
from a swiss mountain chalet to a paris
room to the chiro room 27 different
countries or cities are represented by
via kiske owns the hotel pumping why do
you want to bring the world together in
it what is so because it suits these
times of globalization to show people
the world isn't so big after all so
pulses
they keep it one special about each room
gala to Houston each room has its own
special features of course but I think
the most unusual is Malolo we've put two
tons of sand into it oh jeez the South
Sea room let's go look at
and the down under room is pretty
special too it's weird everything is
upside down do the guests have to strap
themselves into bed that's what I tell
the guests when they arrive I say that
in the evening will bring a trampoline
and they can jump up and we'll tie them
in of course it's really just a normal
room with ordinary beds ok alles klar
as a man who has traveled a long way I
should be able to recognize the world
rooms just by touch
this sofa and these columns feel like
the Paris room wrong it's the Marrakech
room this room is narrow with bamboo
poles Tokyo right a wood-burning stove
and a cooking pot the Swiss Alps wrong
again it's the Ottawa room a romantic
bed and a heart-shaped chair definitely
the Paris room yes skis in the corner
this is the Swiss room and the sand
means you can't miss the South Sea room
422 okay I've traveled a lot but I can't
yet recognize everything in my sleep
back to facts for years Germans were
undisputed travel champions now the
Chinese and Americans have overtaken us
at least by the money they spend at the
warmest times of the year as for
destinations 31.2 percent of Germans
prefer their own country followed by
Spain at 12.3 percent and Italy at 8.2
percent but Germany is also a popular
destination for tourists from abroad in
twenty eleven twenty eight point four
million of them visited us Germany is
such a popular travel destination
however I decide to spend the night in
the Cairo room after all
now it's time for me to say goodbye to
the big wide world after this
international in gym it so I'm scooting
on through the beautiful German
countryside
I